so why would you want to take apple
cider vinegar
before bed well there's many reasons i'm
going to talk about the
blood sugar reason acetic acid which is
the main acid in apple cider vinegar
is very anti-glycemic what does that
mean
it means it reduces your blood sugars
after a meal
acetic acid also helps you reduce blood
sugars in the morning
there's something that occurs called the
dawn phenomena or dawn effect
where you wake up and your blood sugars
are higher
now normally when you wake up your blood
sugars should be low because you didn't
eat all night long
and especially if you're on keto and
you're not eating carbohydrates
why in the world would your blood sugars
be high
well that's because that high blood
sugar is not coming
from your diet it's coming from your
liver
your liver is making extra glucose from
protein and fat
and ketones okay that's called
gluconeogenesis
the formation of new sugar from
non-carbohydrate
sources and the reason why it's doing
that is because you have
insulin resistance you have a problem
with your blood sugars you can be
pre-diabetic
or a diabetic if you're not a
pre-diabetic or diabetic you just have
insulin resistance that's all that means
all right so now why does acetic acid
also vinegar lower your blood sugars
well number one it blocks the enzymes to
break down starches
so if you're not breaking down the
starches the starches can go through you
and not get absorbed number two acetic
acid
reduces the liver's production of
gluconeogenesis
the formation of new sugar and this is
very important if you're a diabetic
you should be taking apple cider vinegar
before bed
you will wake up with your blood sugars
better and that means
the need for medication comes down and
number three the reason why acetic acid
helps your blood sugars
is because acetic acid makes insulin
more sensitive which is going to improve
insulin resistance and it's going to
increase the need for more insulin
and help your pancreas to produce less
insulin
so it's going to help hyperglycemia as
well as
hypoglycemia so if you have
hyperglycemia or low blood sugar
definitely start taking apple cider
vinegar before
bed and even after meals i would
recommend
two tablespoons in a glass of water if
you haven't seen my other videos on
apple cider vinegar
i put the link down below check it out
hey before you go if you're benefiting
from
any of my content i would love
to hear about your success story please
share it
in the link down below